منطقه مستلزمات المطبخ هذه بالسوق الشعبي
وسط الخرطوم جرت العاده ان تمتلئ بالباعه
والمتسوقين في شهر رمضان لاقتناء ما يميز
مائده افطار السودانيين
هذا العام حضر الباعه لكن غاب المشترون
والله في الكرسي ساعه ساعه ونص ساعتين
ممكن ثلاثه ساعات اربعه ساعات تكون ما
يجيك زبون والله الناس
يعني حتى
بيجيك تعبان يقول لك يا اخي انا والله
اشتريت حاجه
التجار هنا ضعف القوه الشرائيه لدى
المواطنين سببا رئيسيا في ضعف الاقبال على
الشراء السنه هبوط جديده بالنسبه للقوات
الشرائيه
يعني
لكن القوه الشرعيه ضعيفه شويه
السودان الذي يعيش ازمه اقتصاديه كبيره
يشكو مواطنه تعاظم الضغط عليهم خلال الشهر
المبارك
الاسعار العاليه شديد يعني اصوات زياده
كثيره من السنه اللي فاتت يعني
اشتريت فول على اسعار زائده يشتريت
البليده كل الحاجات بتاعه رمضان يعني
في زياده يعني خياليه يعني انا ما عارفه
الحاصل شنو في البلد دي ولا في رقيب ولا
في حسيبه يعني
التكاتف ومراعاته حال عموم المواطنين عند
تسعير السلع مطالب تجد طريقها الى التجار
هو شريط ضعيفه جدا جدا ناس ما صرفت
مرتباته دي كلها عشان كده بتاع السوق ذاته
عشان الايجار السوق لانه لو قاعد كده
وقوفه المستهلك السوداني عاجزا امام غلاء
الاسعار وشكوى التجاري من الكاسات كلها
عوامل قد تجعل موائد الصائمين هذا العام
اكثر تواضعا والمظاهر الاحتفاليه اقل فرحا
سالم الهاشمي العربي الخرطوم